an undercover operation revealed TSA
screening at airports fails most of the
time investigators found that screeners
missed test weapons and bombs at baggage
checkpoints more often than not Kris Van
Cleave is at Reagan National Airport
that's right outside Washington DC with
how the TSA is now responding Chris good
morning
well good morning this latest round of
checkpoint failures follows similar
results are actually a little bit worse
a couple of years ago and that prompted
a system-wide retraining of TSA officers
to try to improve performance that
appears to not have really worked out
now the House Homeland Security
Committee decided to open yesterday's
hearing to the public because these
findings are so urgent
we found that briefing disturbing that's
how Republican Mike McCaul the chair of
the House Homeland Security Committee
opened the hearing in that classified
briefing members learned DHS
investigators found more than 70% of the
time undercover officers were able to
get through TSA checkpoints with mock
knives guns and explosives just two
years ago testing found a 95 percent
failure rate the DHS Office of Inspector
General made eight classified
recommendations based on the undercover
operation in a statement TSA said it
takes the OIG findings very seriously
and are implementing measures that will
improve screening effectiveness at
checkpoints both members of Congress and
the TSA support replacing old checkpoint
scanners with new CT scanners like the
ones we were first to show you back in
March mark lost rose from analogic a
company developing the technology in
this system we use high-powered
algorithms to detect explosives
TSA administrator David pukowski told
Congress the CT technology is the most
effective way to keep passengers safe
but the cost is a major hurdle to invest
in the CT technology requires funding
above what TSA currently has Frank Zulu
foe is a former director of the Homeland
Security Advisory Council he says as
long as terrorists target airports the
TSA cannot be complacent they're looking
for vulnerabilities that can be
exploited and we need to make sure that
we can push push that as far as we can
to minimize
risk over the summer the TSA did begin a
limited pilot project testing those CT
scanners about a year behind schedule
just last week they announced an
additional four million dollar
investment but the airlines really would
like to see this technology in place
American has offered to buy some of
these scanners for the TSA to speed up
the limited deployment charlie thanks
Chris